you deserve credit for that oh yeah I do
Helen is long dead ha ha ha ha ha ha Syd
my ways tell me from seeing her again
well you wasted time you're alive like
200 years hope you are prepared to die
because my 15 will ensure every ounce of
die Oh No oh I'm too skilled for this oh
what's that
ah yeah here is that what is that it's
nothing ha ha it's like an old-school
boss battle I love it oh look at that
oh man ok what do I do
besides dodge
I don't know think of shaking shaking
chickie
even the music is like in a way the hell
oh this is why they gave me so much lot
now barely conscious up all better
Oh rock rock take that oh yeah so strong
Oh boom oh damn it
few cuts and bruises ah not supposed to
strike the same place twice
ah what about this what about that oh
I'm so sure
ha ha ha did you see me throw that rock
calm the best okay as with every problem
in magnesia throw a rock at it
ah hey what the heck it's not fair I
wasn't even in the beam you just did
that on purpose
rock rock give me a rock
give me rock there it is there it is
gimme gimme
Oh No Oh too late hey what the hell
Daniel grow some muscles such a wimp
get it ah you got to be kidding me
you god damn it Daniel how about a jump
shot maybe maybe that's it damn it
Daniel
what's wrong with you get it run out of
this you oh you son of them you son of a
[ __ ] Daniel have to carry on shut up
I know okay
alright got the rock Jesus is just
stupid
jump get it there we go why do you delay
the inevitable you mean your death I'm
accelerating that inevitability oh man
this is unfair I'm I'm dodging these
things but it's just hitting me anyway
or maybe I'm not maybe I'm just being
stupid standing still totally not going
to hit me if I stand still up not miss
rock rock me bro
ah oh no I'm out of I gotta make this
count a kick-out do it Daniel you son of
a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a mother I better kill you
I'm gonna kill you Daniel if you don't
get this it's right there you you mother
I'm gonna I hate you so much
there we go finally huh what oh come on
I didn't even have a chance it spun
right behind me what the hell fine I'll
play your game oh this isn't fair I
don't see where they spun is this fair
no no it's not
okay what the heck e heck yeah
okay running running this circle
yeah you should have they're dumb as
bricks nowhere near as smart as I am
oh come on I can't run fast I'm hurt
I have no laudanum left you boned me
over Daniel cuz you couldn't throw uh
okay
all right whatever here we go oh that
was stupid that was that was my own
stupid fault I did that
Oh what
ah okay
I don't know maybe maybe that was me is
this bond behind me again oh come on oh
this is just pitiful this is pitiful
it's pitiful pitiful oh I might edit
this just to not have so many failures
in it
where is he it spawns from nowhere I
can't see where and a king enough okay
enough okay finally God hate you so much
I hate you so much
Oh so much let me just dagger you please
let me dagger you oh I'm gonna dagger
you so hard I get out of here yeah yes
crushing no fu buddy how's my [ __ ] come
on this is the worst
this is the worst ending a horror game
with this is not a good idea huh
have you ever seen the doom movie okay
you don't end a suitor movie with a
fistfight okay I'll just leave it at
that
it makes no sense and it took Victor so
didn't happen
I'm going crazy again it's the number of
Requiem all over again
I lose my mind I'm gonna murder someone
and it better be on Xander because if
not it's gonna be Daniel okay I'm trying
to avoid I'm not I'm not moving I'm not
moving I'm not moving not moving cuz F
this man
okay now I go and I plunge the [ __ ]
dagger through your old [ __ ] heart
yeah guess it yeah you did Auggie's yeah
I pulled you where's the shadow here I
don't know don't think it's out to kill
me good oh man I hate you so much I
should investigate okay if you think
it's a good idea ah ah ah I should have
cut this into two parts because it is a
long one huh what's this oh this is my
house yay I'm in my house again
hello mousie huh my pet mousie how does
it mean why would it aid me huh cuz I'm
so great and it realized how great I was
maybe oh wait I smashed these oh yeah
unless unless Boom Bang II boom smash oh
Super Deluxe chair oh yeah
/ me bang boom bang ah me boom alright
get it oh why my soul so slow what if
his shadow was still chasing Alexander I
mean what is that supposed to mean hello
chairs my old friend knew he was still
alive in the other realm
I think the shadow is chasing Alexander
in the first place was it was just
Daniel right I don't know I don't know
I'm so slow why is it because I'm racked
that must be it perhaps it's needed my
aid to kill him once for all oh I didn't
need its help I
put that dagger in his face oh man okay
finally I'm gonna climb back into bed on
we're gonna go to I sleep
Alexander used the orbs too long in his
soul simply passing to another realm
wasn't he needed to die indefinitely huh
no indefinitely he needed to die
definitely he needed a definitive death
I have a bad feeling about this
something Bad's gonna happen
yep totally totally something bad it's
gonna happen I need some sleep not just
yet there's some mysteries here I'm us
all up no pepper nappy-nap uh uh what uh
uh oh that was it
ah that's nothing okay that was a
fantastic mod very scary up until the
ending like no joke I was having the
best time of my life that was one of the
that was one of the scariest things
going through that the entire thing just
looking at entire mod it was one of the
scariest mods I've ever played right up
there with amnesia but the ending you
don't end a game that's all horror and
stealth based and trying to hide from
monsters like that and I mean I'm not
being overly critical that's just my one
problem with it you saw that was
problematic because the mechanics are
not meant for that but you know he did
something unique so I got to give him
credit for that but anyway go play it's
abduction it's great
it'll be scared out of your mind so
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in the next game
bye bye